qué balance se puede hacer actualmente
del acceso a la prevención y
tratamientos contra esta enfermedad
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
el balance nos dice que es preocupante
estamos con una lucha contra la falta de
inversión
este año el informe de Naciones Unidas
nos dice cómo las desigualdades se ha
convertido en una amenaza para poder
alcanzar el fin del sida para el 2030
que es la meta de las Naciones Unidas
bueno y justamente algo que resalta la
ONU es la importancia de invertir
recursos en investigación para el avance
de los tratamientos en estos momentos se
puede hablar de que esa inversión es
suficiente
no la inversión es un reto los países
ricos están cada vez portando la la
inversión al VIH y en los recursos
financieros es un reto a nivel mundial
bueno y otro tema que genera una fuerte
polémica es que pese a que es una
enfermedad que se puede controlar para
evitar el contagio hay una hay aún una
gran estigmatización de los pacientes
Cuáles son los desafíos al respecto
sí en este momento una persona con VIH
en tratamiento que esté indetectable esa
persona no transmite el virus eso es
importantísimo entenderlo porque una
persona en ese con tratamiento
indetectable es el final de esa
infección no solamente puede estar
saludable ella misma asistitino no se lo
pasará a nadie así que es importantísimo
el acceso a diagnóstico que las personas
sepan su diagnóstico que puedan tener
acceso al medicamento y que pueda
mantenerse en tratamiento Ese es el gran
reto que tenemos en términos de
investigación es el el acceso a estas a
estos medicamentos bueno Y cuál se puede
considerar el principal avance que se ha
hecho desde que se descubrió la
enfermedad hasta este momento en materia
de tratamientos
Bueno hay un último tratamiento que
antirretroviral que inyección y se lo
pone cada dos meses eso es un avance
enorme ya que las personas que tienen
acceso a este medicamento se tiene que
poner solamente hacer inyecciones al año
y ya están bien